Dai amo non starci male alla fine se lo meritava
Dici?
Certo ti ricordi quella volta che ha messo like a quella tipa?
Ma era sua cugina
E quella volta che è uscito con gli amici di nascosto?
veramente me lo aveva detto, avevo lasciato il telefono a casa
Vabbè senti se l`hai fatto è perché lui se lo meritava comunque gli hai dato una lezione così se sveglia
ma forse rigargli la macchina è stato un po troppo....
Gli hai rigato la macchina...
E va be amo che ti frega c`è....almeno impara
Ma adesso mi ha lasciato...
E allora amo te ne trovi un altro tanto lui non ti meritava
Amo io vado!
Ma dove vai così scollata copriti
Ma fa caldo!!
Copriti...dai
Basta una folata di vento e ti prendi un accidente su chiuditi
Ecco così...e tieni questa è la pasta al forno
Ma abbiamo appena mangiato
Non importa, non vedi che sei magra? Devi mangiare su! Ciao tesoro
Quando arrivi mandami un messaggino
Si.....
Amo, allora, sono indecisa gli scrivo o non gli scrivo?
Scrivigli assolutamente
Dici?
Però se gli scrivo magari pensa che sia una sottona, se non gli scrivo rischio magari di perderlo per sempre
E infatti dovresti scrivergli
Ma cosa gli scrivo?
Inizia con un ciao, come stai
Ma ciao come stai ti penso o ciao come stai usciamo?
Ce so uscita...pure con questo...con questo pure...
Questo non mi ricordo aspe...
Si amo l' hai conosciuto l' anno scorso al mio compleanno
Ma che davvero?
Può essere, stavo tutta ubriaca...va be roba da niente va avanti
Ce so uscita....
Ammazza questo che bono è stata veramente una notte di passione...
O...è il mio fidanzato
No amo, mi son sbagliata scusa, questo è praticamente molto simile a quell' amico nostro con qui sono uscita....bono....anche lui bono però no...non è lui
Amo dobbiamo studiare abbiamo la verifica settimana prossima
E settimana prossima ci pensiamo poi, lasciami guardare la tv
E no adesso spegni e andiamo a studiare
Facciamo così io ti ripeto tutto il programma per 30 volte così magari la impari
Si amo tranquilla sono in macchina...sto cercando parcheggio...guarda sto st**** me ne ha appena rubato uno
Non ce la faccio più amo non mi vuole nessuno
Siete tutte fidanzate e io so l'unica che è sola da una vita
Non ti preoccupare, lo troverai un fidanzato guarda che anche io quando mi sono fidanzata con Luca prima ero come te ed è arrivato quando meno me lo aspettavo
Io già mi vedo
Con dieci gatti zitella per sempre
E che tragica
Morirò da sola, te lo dico io
Amo te l'ho detto che mamma ha vinto la lotteria
Che fortunata e che andiamo in gita a  New York con la scuola?
New York? Va be..noi ci portano a Predappio
Amo lo so la tua sezione è un po sfigata te l' ho detto di passare alla mia è TOP
Ma devi proprio mangiare davanti a me, non tutti mangiano e non ingrassano come te
Amo è questione de costituzione se potessi ti giuro che ti regalerei il metabolismo mio....però non si può
Amo
Si sono ancora da quella sfigata
Ma ti pare se non fosse per farmi fare i compiti io non ci avrei mai avuto a che fare con quella.
Aspetta sta arrivando
Eccomi!!
Amore....tesoro ma mi hai fatto i compiti?
Tutti qua
Grazie sei proprio un angelo...te l' ho mai detto che sei  l' amica più speciale che ho?
Grazie
Amo a chi l'hai detto
A nessuno te lo giuro
Beh forse solo alla Chiara, però lei la mia migliore amica ed è anche amica tua
Quindi non penso che lo andrà a raccontare in giro
E poi a chi l' hai detto?
E poi forse anche a Martina però mi sono sentita così tanto in colpa che sono corsa in chiesa per confessarmi
E una volta uscita dalla chiesa ho incontrato....tua mamma
E quindi e quindi?
E quindi..glielo ho detto
Però secondo me non l'ha presa benissimo
Forse scoprire che sua figlia ha perso la verginità l'ha fatta un po sentire male infatti è caduta per terra, è svenuta
Ma tu sei pazza
No amo non andare...ti voglio bene lo sai che di me ti puoi fidare
Prima che torni
Ricordatevi di iscrivervi al canale e se questo video arriverà 100.000 like girerò la seconda parte e racconterò il suo segreto a tutta Milano